Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
x-men video you probably just saw the new casting
news for the new x-men team that they're gonna
use in the upcoming x-men movie in marvel phase
six like the new mcu version of the x-men it's one
of the mystery movies that they didn't announce at
comic-con there's a lot of mutant-related stuff
happening in marvel phase 5 so we're setting up
like big x-men related stuff happening in marvel
phase six like that's why deadpool 3 is happening
in marvel phase six because there's so much more
mutant stuff happening in marvel phase six so
we'll break it all down and explain what's going
on with the new x-men team right now because we
literally just got a huge mcu x-men teaser during
the miss marvel series if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we also have the x-men 97 episodes that are airing
next year of course i'll do videos for all those
episodes too because they're branding it as a
marvel studios project so it sounds like they
have like this larger plan behind the scenes to
weave in the classic 90s x-men animated series
into mcu continuity technically we call it the
marvel cinematic multiverse now instead of the
marvel cinematic universe so if you want to talk
about just like the traditional one world
where most of these movies take place like
the earth-based movies you talking about what
they're calling now the 616 main mcu universe
but like we just saw patrick stewart come back
as a version of professor x in the 838 universe
during doctor strange 2 and they baked a lot of
x-men the animated series easter eggs into that
version because of his appearance the way he acted
and they even used the theme song from x-bend
animated series when he appeared for the first
time wheeling in in the same yellow floaty chair
even though they killed him off during that movie
rip patrick stewart did say that he would love to
come back and do something similar as another
multiverse version of the character so don't
worry like that's not the last time you'll ever
see patrick stewart we still have a version of
secret wars coming up but like they just did
the same thing in the miss marvel finale where
they revealed that kamala khan miss marvel was
a mutant in the mcu using the same x-men the
animated series theme song when talking about it
like they really want you to think about the x-men
so clearly kevin feige marvel do have a
larger plan for weaving in all the core
x-men characters to like the main 616 mcu universe
but there is a new clip that's going around that
you probably saw in your feeds with giancarlo
esposito talking about how he's met with marvel
recently about being in that new x-men movie
i'll play the clip here he's amazing so it is
really cool he talks about a bunch of different
characters so i have not worked for marvel yet
i've been in a room with them and talked to them
and to answer your question i think what they do
is on the lines of that mythological journey
that joe campbell talked about who happened
to be a friend of george lucas that george
lucas put into his stories they do the same
thing it is our dream and intention to save the
world our environment to save the world from
greedy corporations to uplift the world and have
leadership that thinks about us for the people
by the people which means that those future
leaders are in this room right now amen right
and so we want to inspire each other
we want to lift each other up because
what happens when that happens is then we actually
do have a vision and a dream for a new world
then we can actually start to reverse all the
things that we have destroyed that will choke us
if we don't change how we move through this
universe so there's the talk of magneto
there has been talk of who else
are they talking about over here
professor x
pick one pick one i'm gonna go for
something that is a little bit different
i'm gonna go and put it out in the universe that
it is professor x when he's talking about all that
joseph campbell george lucas stuff he's talking
about the idea of the classic hero's journey dan
harmon also does the same thing and uses it as
his famous story will but it's joseph campbell's
hero's journey that he models that on it's all
about boiling down every single hero character arc
to a similar type of journey that their character
goes through during each of their stories so like
you can apply this to any of the marvel characters
in their movies any of the star wars characters
in their movies or disney plus series like the
mandalorian character you can even apply this to
grosgu's character the reason he says george lucas
specifically obviously because he's talking about
all the star wars moth gideon stuff that he does
in the mandalorian but if you didn't know george
lucas is a huge fan of joseph campbell way back
when he was writing the story for the original
star wars movie he used a lot of joseph campbell's
hero's journey to guide him in crafting the luke
skywalker a lot of the other main characters but
then giancarlo esposito says yes he's met with
kevin feige about playing the new professor x it's
only one role that he said he's going after but he
said it is the role that he is most excited about
he also mentions magneto doctor doom when he says
doctor freeze i think he's just misspeaking i
think he meant to say mr freeze and he's talking
about the batman sequels the matt reeves the
robert pattinson version of batman so i'll just
talk about the marvel stuff in this video because
it is a marvel x-men video but to make a fantastic
four joke giancarlo esposito is fantastic
at anything that he does so he'd be amazing
as any of those characters professor x doctor
doom or magneto we're much closer to actually
meeting an mcu version of doctor doom because of
what's happening in black panther wakanda forever
but during the trailer you see this team of
scientists going underwater using all this
gear that is not wakandan gear trying to find more
vibranium underwater and that sort of causes a lot
of the problems in the movie that lead to neymar
eventually declaring war on wakanda like during
the trailer you see this team forcing a bunch of
what look like wakandans forcing them into this
facility here because they're all after vibranium
and the report is is the team of scientists is
actually being backed by doctor doom like doctor
doom is funding their research in finding more
vibranium because he wants it but he'll be sort
of like this figure behind the scenes pulling
the strings whereas like the main characters in
the movie are like namor the wakandan characters
and riri williams introducing her character so
like you already have a billion characters in
the movie that's why doctor doom isn't like a main
character during the film they're just gonna like
tease him towards the end of the film like oh it
was doctor doom that was behind all this the whole
time there are also a lot of people that want to
see them do the comic book secret wars twist when
we get to avengers 5 kang dynasty in avengers 6
secret wars where doctor doom winds up becoming
god emperor doom but because of the way they're
doing things in the mcu it sounds like a lot more
of this plot is turning on the king multiverse
war and king the conqueror himself so like the
big idea with avengers 5 is that they're doing the
avengers infinity war and avengers end game sort
of big cliffhanger time jump situation where you
have like a huge cliffhanger downer ending where
the avengers lose at the end of avengers 5 and
because of all the incursions secret wars time
runs out the idea is that at the end of avengers
5 the final multiverses that are left in reality
will wind up colliding with each other you'll
have like the final incursions and they'll create
a version of battle world and that'll be the
big cliffhanger moment leading into avengers 6.
in the comics doctor doom was like a much bigger
figure in what happened with the creation of
battle world during secret wars so we'll see if
they also wind up using him for a lot of that plot
too it'll be cool either way it just sounds like
in the mcu movie version of all this kang will be
a much bigger figure than he was in the comic book
versions as for magneto i never really considered
giancarlo esposito as a version of magneto even
though he'd be great as that character too i think
people have been fan casting him as that for
a while it's just that when most people think
of fan casting giancarlo esposito they're mostly
thinking of villain characters because all of his
most iconic characters recently have been villains
like gus fring or moff gideon in the mandalorian
but i've also been hearing fan casting for him as
the new professor x in that new x-men movie for a
couple years now since kevin feige announced that
they were actually working on it even though they
didn't talk about the new x-men movie at their big
comic-con panel kevin feige said he doesn't want
to wait that long before doing like legit x-men
and mutants in the mcu which essentially means
that he plans on doing it before avengers 6 secret
wars during marvel phase six not after in marvel
phase seven the official beginning of marvel phase
six is going to be that new fantastic four movie
we always knew we were gonna get the new fantastic
four team before we got the new x-men team
so that's why you're seeing them slowly set up all
this mutant stuff in the main 616 marvel universe
like the miss marvel finale scene but because
we're in the middle of the multiverse saga right
now there's so much multiverse going on we just
saw a multiverse version of patrick stewart come
back we will see some of those legacy actors from
the fox marvel films come back as their characters
from the multiverse so it sounds like when they
do the new mcu versus the x-men team it'll be a
combination like brand new recasted versions of
the characters like new mcu versions from our
main 616 universe but also a couple multiverse
characters too so like there could have been
mutants in the mcu born a long time ago but it was
relatively rare thing but then you have a bunch of
infinity gauntlet snaps bunch of cosmic energy
release a bunch of messing with the multiverse
from a bunch of different characters and then
suddenly a bunch more mutants start popping up
but everyone post all your theories in
the comments below who do you want to be
in that new x-men movie like if they're gonna
bring in new versions of the characters who do
you want to play all those new x-men characters
and remember deadpool 3 a lot of other mutant
stuff will be happening in movies just in general
like there'll be mutants in other people's movies
throughout marvel phase six even in marvel phase
five a little bit too in related news all my
she-hulk episodes are going to be starting really
soon make sure you enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that everyone click here for my new
daredevil versus she hulk trailer video and click
here for my brand new guardians of the galaxy
3 trailer video in easter eggs from comic con
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!